let you be a function that and especially
real numbers like lg prime de
knight de veggie be defined is gee
privacy code expert about ex-minister
power on which infosys gee increasing
what kind of symmetry of glass jelly fish
eye wengie is increasing
well be the answer  is all we need is 3
prime what cities glass and caesar was in
hills so three increasing that i
want to be on which infosys dat
first to review with respect ex van
rituals is a joy to be greater than zero
aviator change respect access greater
degree of  the positive then your
function the self is going to be the
increasing
and so this couple or two is three times
procession mars living in spin spect i
have the structured is expressions i do
know is that cubic meter de diego origi
aim a bit more with arie  click between
the qwirkle point of the critical values
for gee
so critical
critical point
for
jeee and distro miner even critical
point ar that's my jeep timex
easy peasy euro of jeep time and wax is
undefined
is andy foger how your video that critical
pointer curricle  values ​​and why do
while find is to place boxes so that
on possible places where the sign to
change the side of jeep time to change
like gee private mexico lucio
full gee primer action code cyrus can
i my new reason rico so euro
drop halifax queer risk  dessert
of exsis-i cosimo
de' see all the place where no privacy
cosimo and weather grime effect en divined
was kpn definer pin-o-meter becomes an
define de an american undefined in
diameter you see and
so des critères graphics my de
propel risk ziro x minus 2 zero zero
or action code zoey have your critical
pointer curricle values ​​here hear
subscribe do we are crafting
spray mill number line and the think
about what the prime is doing in die
intervals between the critical points
will start at  ziggo
one
3 and demos culture
9 dupont and we have curricle point the
idea that in magenta we have critical
point erection chose hiero
hi there and we have a critical point
mexico mexico sidewalk ride on and
soloist think about what the prime is
doing in die  is in the interface between
the curricle value for other side of the
good guys soloist built in with first
built in this makes sense to i do it in
this purple color
plastic body interval intention between
negative find that and the is euro
so nutrition gladys in there full so negative
infiniti
and see your bed open interval
please look at the prime
the number one there is silence in the
library and own the value
scorecard why so this is going to be
positive no but the the name meter
means negative choose number fracture
of we  first i make it a negative
number and looked it back home power one
economic turbaniformis a negative
number so we just db9 de
suriname positive or both negative
so jeep time you going to be negative
salami ride a sound is a er vol aan
dit in er  full of that this
jeep timex is less than zero if i have
something about it why do when the visual notes
that lead i argue about 13 euros
take a piece of plastic that in there vol
between theory and to write about here so
this is the one in there vol  van see euro
tutu those openings full as good as possible
just with 3 prime effect here 20 and
ex square and eating greater than zero
and sister to including see here the
single what is is for show join the beat
for this anthology for your ex mind  you
where access greater than zero tax
are you something like that you need the numbers and
bakes wai wai meines 2 is 9 just
quiet the ninth values ​​in so the name
everyone there so dusty it 9 the
value are so the name meter diameter
will be in the bie  against negative youtube
the rf power
well now missed the negative already so
this is going to be
negative become so quiet have 3 prime is
less than zero
edgar will you quiet her
jeep time and wax is less than zero
en and last i miss that er vol
i  that interval of two then three then
two
what a ureters fit all this can
be positive for any i get unique
lucio
and so the name better coverage value
greater than 2 pertain to from which
to give you up positive you the ticket
of power will you  positive
it is alcohol in the library address
so this is the interval where the prime
and wax is greater than zero
will have to innovative 3 increasing
rollator gee primax is greater than zero
so you can before me from 2 2
internet die horeca this ride like  this
wiki running ex is greater than to either
way of for every one who is 3 prime effect
is ritual and
your function gee is going to be
increasing